ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we are uh
we just got back from a uh
meeting not a meeting what is an
engagement mm-hmm with one of the bigger
tech people here in austin
yeah and uh it was a lot of fun we've
got whitney webb later on on the show
uh talking about some things coming down
the
pike with the vaccine passport
and um we met this dude through a mutual
guide he was a nice guy brilliant guy
very smart very successful um when we
walked in
he felt i felt like he didn't really
know us or knew who we were what we did
um i think he only has a slightly better
understanding of it after the two hours
but we played pickleball which is a
game it's like uh it's a cross between
tennis and ping pong and it's very
interesting when you meet like
high-powered successful people a lot of
times they're like do something athletic
in front of me let's see if you can do
something
uh do you have a competitive edge do you
want to win you know it was like that
kind of
they said there was going to be a lunch
we walked in there was a hummus and a
strawberry so it was like not exactly
but that's fine they're healthy that's
what they eat you know what i mean tech
successful
it was a scene from ex machina is what
it was but it was lovely it was lovely
and um
you know the house is you know
tremendous and beautiful and uh and then
they go let's play some pickleball do
you guys play pickleball and i was like
i don't really know what it is but i'm
sure um
i will do it and then um it's a cross
between
tennis and ping pong so you have it's
like a court in a gym
and you're playing uh pickleball and um
me and ben of course are gonna play
together but then they said well you're
both beginners
you should play with the other people
there so we did
and it was now you look at me and you
look at bannon you're like oh ben
he's going to be the athlete ben was so
bad at this game
and he kept cheating by going into this
area where you were not supposed to go
into
um it was so embarrassing
now they're in gym clothes me and ben of
jeans on cause we didn't really know
it was raining we didn't know what was
gonna happen and um
i was doing pretty damn good like a few
of the other people they were like
you're gonna be really good at this i
had a great you know because i
i play tennis as a kid a little bit and
i i know how to really just kind of
hit the ball just have it sail right
over the net ben was aggressively
you know we're playing doubles and ben
was aggressively trying to
like hit the ball in front of the other
people and then just failing miserably
at it
did you know how bad you were doing i
charged the net a couple of times it was
embarrassing
did you feel how how bad you were doing
i had a couple were you shocked who told
you that
well i can't say his name but he he was
not
i was doing very well you were great at
serving
very good you know what you know what
see this is what he's trying to do
i was doing really really well okay
i do what i do well and ben likes to
pretend he does everything well
i was i'm an amazing server and then i
could also do the volley but i also feel
like after i've done the serve
i should be done for the point i don't
want to run around the court like a
psychopath
it's unbecoming of a man of my stature
so i do the serve and then the other
person runs around like a monkey
and then i was good at returning too
he's being a piece of [ __ ]
because he was he was genuinely
embarrassing and there's a
these are really rich successful people
judging us and the pig is murdering it
running around the court doing what i
have to do uh and then
this guy's uh uh family walked in and
then they were all staring there
watching ben just
wildly run around and it was so
it was hard to see it was hard to see
for me because i felt bad for ben i was
embarrassed for ben
we'd never done anything athletic before
and you
you thought you were thinking that i was
just gonna not be good at all
that's not true at all that's what you
felt no i know but what happened
yes pipe down what happened was
i was phenomenal i was pretty damn good
the guy looked at me and said you are
going to be very good at this
the other guy the main guy said you were
good when did he say that
he actually said twice he was like wow
that was really impressive when i was up
there like i had a couple times where it
was
that's one isolated thing that's not a
review of your performance for the
entire day
it's what you did one or two good things
i don't think i missed a serve though
like i didn't i didn't had to serve out
of bounds though i had the services
i was just saying between me and you
would you argue that i did a little
better
uh oh wow overall yeah overall you won
more games
well that would be that's they care
about winning
you understand what metric are you
deciding i won more games what metric
are you going off of
um inner belief
well anyway
after the game uh we hung out and ate uh
hummus and it was nice it's a matcha
delicious yeah so matcha it was uh uh
lovely meeting new people here in
uh austin texas and um
you know we're not influenced by anyone
ever on this show we're never influenced
i've nev i've never in like i am never
influenced
by anyone on this show like i like i
meet successful powerful people all the
time
but i'm never like a guy who's like oh i
should start evangelizing on the behalf
of anyone
i never felt that i've never felt that
you know what i mean yeah
i i do and this is unrelated this is
an unrelated point i was thinking this
morning
about what a great company palantir is
while i had my eggs
and i just i woke up and i said what a
great
company it is because they have all the
information
of the people and that's what you want
you want you want all the information
to be in a place and i think that's
they do it good they do it well
so i'm a fan of them yeah great
investment
it's a great investment yeah i also
would like to say
i like the central intelligence agency
i like them they're efficient
they're mysterious
and i think that we have to relax when
we are
um always with the bringing up the bad
things they did in the past
enough with that stop that
there everyone's made mistakes when i
was young i kicked my friend
i wasn't becoming of my character that's
not who i am
so i like the central intelligence age i
like
it and i think it's good
and i don't think you should
be upset if people want to listen
to what you're saying on the phone
or read your email i don't
think that's a problem i don't think
it's a big deal
i don't think it's a big deal if people
know what medications you're on and if
they need to be refilled
i i i'm okay with that
and you should be too
i think we asked too many questions do
you understand
i understand what you're saying and i'm
just saying i'm an independent
broadcaster who has thoughts
that are in his head that he says them
they are not given to me by anyone and
they are
i am not influenced by anyone
but god damn it if jeff bezos isn't a
great [ __ ] guy
he's a great guy
and i i want things to be delivered to
me and
with a drone right yes
that's what i'm saying i'm saying those
things and only those things
mark zuckerberg gets a bad rap
he's a sweet boy who's created a thing
that's a little wacky
do you understand
jack dorsey is a fine man he's a fine
man he's created a platform that makes
me feel better about the world and our
ability to
have a meaningful dialogue i love you
jack
do you understand whoever owns
page i love them the patreon uh people
you are good p hey eric schmidt
these are i i'm just saying
that i lo i love people in tech
i like them i think it's important that
we
get off their back get off their back
i like that they don't have an
expression all the time on their face
i like that i think that's nice how many
people do you meet where they have a
when you look at them they have an
expression and they go hello or and you
see
oh you're happy or you're sad or you're
embarrassed i like when there is none
i think it's refreshing i think it's
modern
i think it's modern i think it's very
when someone looks at you and does it
you can't quite tell if they are
if they're real i like that i
i enjoy that that's what i like
you don't the people are so caught up in
like
oh i should be able to say what i want i
don't think so
i don't think so i believe
that you should get a list of words that
you can say
which will be shorter than the ones that
you cannot and that'll make it easier
for you
i i'm just saying i am saying that i'm
i am not i have not been co-opted at all
okay at all i'm just
saying
that i'm
i want to get the vaccine
more than twice
i'd like to get it six or seven times
is what i'm saying do you understand and
a lot of people are like
oh oh you're in texas and you're meeting
all these uh
people and you're you're they're
influencing you no
no that's not it i'm realizing
how lucky i am that there is an industry
taking care of me
taking care of us all they're taking
care of us all
thank the lord i like it
i like people pooping in the street
i don't think it's a big deal i think if
if you think it's a big deal you should
start a company and buy a house
out of the city but i think people
should be able to poop in the street
sorry i'm a humanitarian
okay so i wanted to get that out of the
way because people are always
nervous how and and when we'll be
co-opted
so there's not i just want to let people
know there is no
fear of that at all no fear of that at
all
okay let's do an ad break here we do we
do have an end hold on hold on let's get
it
let's get the end here
the tim dylan show is proud to be
sponsored by the national security
agency
the national security agency we're
watching out for you
here at the nsa we are pioneering new
ways to make
americans safe that is our top priority
keeping you safe by using many different
ways to get information
it's not really important how we get the
information it's important
we do with it what we think is best the
national security agency
we're the we love you
all right that was our first ad break
let's do a second ad break because we
roll into
moderna as now sponsoring the tim dillon
show
moderna has developed a vaccine it is
fun
and it is two shots you will love it and
enjoy it
and afterwards it will be
shown that you have taken it in a wallet
so you can get into basketball games
and concerts moderna is always working
hard
to try to solve the problems of tomorrow
just have to get these heads out of the
way folks it's just
the tim dylan show is proud to be
sponsored by the bill and melinda gates
foundation
bill and melinda are here to help they
want you to know that
bill has spent years tirelessly trying
to solve every problem that has ever
arisen
from climate change to vaccines
and diseases and overpopulation
and how these all go together somehow
bill and melinda are very excited
to help people through their charitable
donations and
foundations and contributions
on this show i have said things about
bill that are not true
because i'm a stupid pig don't listen
to the stupid pig do your own research
at their website the bill and melinda
gates foundation
because that is where the accurate
information is all other sources
are not to be trusted i am sorry for
what i have said about bill
and melinda gates it was inappropriate
and down right wrong
i wrestle with the guilt of what i have
said about them
sometimes it is so bad that i lay in bed
all day like i have just taken the
much-needed second shot
of the moderna vaccine this ad copy's
good it's not bad
i am very very happy i love bill and
everything he has done for the third
world
and our world let's and all of the
worlds
bill and melinda gates i am very sorry
that i said that warren buffett was a
creepy old goblin
and that him and bill were frauds and
that
they have a plan that if only we had any
clue about it it would
scare us all i apologize for that
i also apologize for continually
bringing up the epstein angle with bill
because bill had no idea what jeffrey
was doing
i'm a fat opportunist who likes to link
people's
is a long head who likes to link people
together that had nothing to do with
each other
it is because i am fat and i am not
thinking clearly that i have
constantly brought up previous
associations with uh jeffrey epstein
i am sorry i want to take this
opportunity to apologize to
bill melinda and warren buffett for all
of my transgressions
and i am excited to welcoming them as
sponsors of my new show
where i will be vaccinated on the table
in front of everyone
so i think it's important that people tr
know and trust us you know what i mean
and that's
because there's so many people out there
right now in the entertainment business
that are
you know people don't trust them but i
feel like we have to kind of
show everybody that just because we're
in austin and just because we know some
of these people
we have not changed who we are like our
core beliefs and values which have
always been a deep love of the
intelligence community
and and big pharma why are
you know are do you people really so
lucky you are
with the pharmaceuticals that
you can get them when you are young and
keep taking them for your entire life
do you realize how lucky you are many
people don't have the chance
to begin a regimen of adderall at three
and then take uh puberty blocking
hormones
at nine and then graduate to
lithium at 12 and then
keep going on a cocktail of different
medications
until uh you're in a grave it is so
nice i just want to throw that out there
i just want to throw that out there
because i think i've been very
hard on the pharmaceutical industry um
i've said that they're selling us junk
cures for products like you know for
problems that they've invented
and i want to say that i'm dead wrong i
am dead
think of this everything i have said
before today i have been dead wrong
dead wrong and
i realized that i i have realized that
i've been dead wrong i think chelsea
handler's doing a good job with her
documentaries about
uh black people
i want more of them i want
more of her content
i i believe in her
and her mission
and if i've ever said anything on this
show that makes people doubt that
it's because i'm uh a bad
person but i'm trying to get better at
that
do you understand yes i do
do you understand now since we left this
person's house my cell phone has not
worked
and i don't i think that's a coincidence
right yeah probably there's something
odd with my car
when i turn it on it makes a weird sound
but i don't think that any of that
is related
do you think we'll be invited back i
hope so they were lovely they were very
fun i had a great time
what are the chances i think 50
okay okay
what do you think um i don't know
i'll get better at pickleball in the
meantime but i hope so
i just want to use this opportunity
why are you why are you i'm not i'm not
i want to use this opportunity
to talk about
my love
my love for
elizabeth holmes
she made one mistake you know
one mistake that's all
you know
why are you all you're all nervous now
i'm not nervous at all
why are you all nervous i'm not nervous
i don't know
you're very nervous you think they're
gonna kill you
you think they'd kill you you think
they'd
waste their time remotely hijacking your
tesla when you and your wife are going
to get oysters
at whatever dump is in austin
you think they'd waste their time
killing
you are you have you not
lost your mind
if they're going to kill anyone it's
going to be me
i don't want anyone to kill you
that's true would not be good
but i was i was i did all the ads that i
was supposed to do
so i don't think we're going to have an
issue
do you think so i enjoyed it and i hope
we're invited again i love our new
sponsors i love our new friends
i and i was wrong to question
why bill gates wanted to shoot a missile
of dust at the sun
that was a mistake i'm sorry about that
i think he i think he should shoot a
missile of whatever he wants at whatever
he wants
i don't you understand that i want my
audience to know
that i have integrity okay
is there anything else we didn't cover
we're doing this bitcoin conference
we are doing this until that email comes
in tomorrow
but we can't we're doing it when is it
can you get the ad this is a real ad
june oh
let's do that let's go right into an ad
perfect yeah right here here you go
what if i told you that bitcoin is the
future of money now what if i told you
it's going to be an actual
in person in the flesh event this year
focus exclusively on bitcoin and it's
going to be the biggest event in bitcoin
history now what if i continue to tell
you that event will happen
in miami florida on june 4th and 5th and
then i tim dillon was going to be there
too would you believe me
it's true the bitcoin 2021 conference is
happening folks it'll be sunny hot miami
florida june
fourth or fifth headlining the
conference will be jack dorsey
founder of twitter chamath ike
he retweets us we like him tony hawk who
is a bitcoiner michael saylor the duda
keeps
taking out a billion dollar loans
against this company to buy bitcoin
and nick sabo he's a fun guy on twitter
tim dillon will also be considered a
headliner if he does a good job with the
ad read
oh there will be a whale day ahead of
the conference if you're rich
like me you need to buy a whale pass and
get there a day earlier on june 3rd
there'll be bitcoin powered we don't
even know what we're doing for this no
one's told us no no one will let us know
no one is told do you think they're just
gonna execute us in front of all these
people
no we've emailed nine times to figure
out what's expected of us
we know we're doing a live podcast we're
doing a live podcast and you're
moderating something
i'm moderating something there'll be
bitcoin-powered arcade games a massive
art gallery with all the most famous
bitcoin artists tony hawk is skating a
half pipe
and much more
an answer party that i'll be opening up
for i i don't even know what's happening
here
this event will be the event of the year
it's going to sell out get your tickets
down go to b
tc what now b dot tc
conference i'll put it on the screen
right here and it'll be in the
description yeah go to b
dot tc slash conference promo code tim
dillon
10 off your ticket price am i selling
tickets to this
yeah yeah but am i getting anything from
that
well you're getting paid to do the
bitcoin conference yeah but i mean
that's not what that's not what i'm
gonna
get people to come to this and then go
if you wanna see if you wanna see me do
a live pod we have no idea
what's going on or what we're doing i
mean that's not the greatest sales pitch
but i genuinely don't know we don't know
but it's going to be fun
because it's always fun yeah yeah but do
you know what we're doing
not a clue right neither i don't know if
your agent doesn't know i don't know
what's going on but
we will be in miami and we're going to
do
a live podcast and then i'm moderating
an event
and it looks like you might be doing
stand-up at an after party or something
i don't know
no one has said anything about it come
learn about bitcoin and celebrate life
and freedom at the bitcoin
2021 conference b
dot tc forward slash conference and use
the code tim dillon ten percent off jack
dorsey is going to be headlining
on twitter is he a bitcoiner yeah yeah
they all are
they all are it should be interesting
i mean i'm wondering
i'm wondering how this is gonna go
you know
like are we gonna be podcasting in like
a half pipe that tony hawk is like
skating in
i don't know
i don't know how this is gonna go
you may want to come and see it to just
see it because i genuinely
do not have an idea it'll be funny
certainly but i don't know
what's gonna happen this will be way
more fun than like a comedy festival or
something 100
yeah i am hoping yeah i believe so
it's a real cultural moment a live tim
dillon show from the biggest bitcoin
conference
i mean it's going to be wild they're
going to talk about everything right all
the coins
dogecoin uh i'm where i want to wear
like a dogecoin
shirt well this one might specifically
just be for bitcoin it looks like oh
okay
but what if i have the dogecoin dog on a
shirt have a little fun
that could be a big hit yeah i mean we
gotta figure something out here
we gotta we gotta do something something
if we put him on the shirt
people can see we're putting the work in
here you know
what else can we do because that was my
idea
do you have any ideas you brought to the
table
well my idea is i i would like us to do
the live podcast with garyvee
i think that would be amazing invitation
to garyvee if you allow me to i would
love it
i would really like i don't know if he's
gonna do it if you know gary let him
know that
we'd like him as a guest i will pay
garyvee money to be on the show
at the bitcoin conference it will be a
lot of fun
it will be like he could coach me as to
how to like start a business
[Music]
what i'd like to do is get garyvee and
bring my friend ryan who's a recovering
heroin addict
to the conference and i'd like to have
gary instruct ryan on how to start
a business that would be
that would be my goal if i could get
gary vee
to instruct my recovering heroin addict
friend
on how to build a brand
that would be my goal but it is a weird
like we don't it's gonna be interesting
but we don't know
we don't know what's going to happen are
people going to sit
and listen i i think
it's like a ted talk thing but with
bitcoin like people are going to sit
around talking i mean but to our podcast
yes yes i believe so we should get a
guest
who are we going to get for well my idea
was gary vee
um i noted i guess noted another guess
could be little xan little zen
yo like bitcoin
but i'm dead serious shouldn't we have a
guess
oh
you're the producer of this show you
went today and made a mess about
pickleball
you lied on the show and said i did you
mean you did nearly the same
we did not you blew a lot of high high
profile things i blew a few of them but
you blew some serious
and i had an amazing serve people
noticed that i had a skill set
yeah i was a little bit chaotic in my
skill set
you were really all over the court and
you kept cheating
you kept going into the kitchen which is
the thing you shouldn't go into that i
was wearing clarks though
if i was wearing tennis shoes i could
have stopped on time yeah i mean
everyone's got a story
but you know that area right by the net
you kept going into and cheating
what about roseanne like i'm dead
serious oh amazing can we fly roseanne
to the bitcoin conference from hawaii
sure
i don't know what we're gonna we gotta
do something here
i'm dead sir paying us money we got to
figure out something
what if we get chamath
to explain bitcoin to roseanne
something like this has got to happen
i'm telling you
we need to get
somebody who needs to explain bitcoin to
someone else who's completely
off the planet that's
the fusion i want to make i want to make
this happen
i want to take a bitcoin expert maybe
i'll just get one of my friends who's
like from long island who's just
completely shot i don't know
but that's what needs to happen here
whitney webb is coming up she's going to
be here to discuss
getting thrown off of patreon
why that happened she's also going to
talk about
vaccine passports why she's skeptical
that the maxwell new charges mean much
we told her we'd have her back if the
maxwell thing goes to trial which we
don't know if it will or not
it's supposed to in july yeah we'll also
be
the we got an episode with stanhope on
the patreon right now the higher tier
because we we kind of [ __ ] them over
we didn't mean to
uh we were going to do a big long
episode with doug and put it out
this week but it just didn't work it
just kind of went off the rails at the
end it was like
this was what we could do here we can't
you know
um but we'll be back there lovely people
love them both
doug and bingo um we'll be back there
uh so we got that rocket and rolling we
got live dates a lot of them are sold
out the
majority of them are sold out um and we
got more being announced all the time
the world's opening up and
uh we're out there having a lot of fun
or
just doing what we have to do as a job
you choose
your choice some of it is fun but you
know
i hope this is fun what about aj
i was kind of thinking that or like
maybe even you know they're shutting
alex jones down they're not letting that
happen
cause what about if alex jones like
charged jack dorsey
on stage he's like you [ __ ]
and jack joyce like who the [ __ ]
brought alex jones and it's like oh the
comedian that we hired
it would be really cool if we like snuck
alex in he stayed at our hotel
and we got him like to enter the back
door he just like like the kool-aid man
just popped into the conference
yeah well now that we've yeah no one
will figure that out now
you just put that plan out there dum-dum
well no i mean it's it's clearly it's
clearly
uh a situation where i we need to bring
in a guess who else
you said alex and then you were thinking
of somebody else oh um
maybe someone's like i was thinking like
not just like maxwell of course
because she's not on bail but i'm trying
to think of someone
we also can't talk to a human trafficker
for goofs
we can't bring on a human trafficker for
a bit people would get angry at that and
rightly so
like yucking it up with just lane
maxwell who's tortured children
there's got to be some line what about
rogan should i email rogan
text him email him a formal offer then
we'll pay him 1500.
to appear
hear me out okay hear me out yeah yeah
hear me out
are you ready yeah yeah are you ready
do you know what i'm about to say no how
well do you know me
very well almost as well as anybody
probably better than anyone that's
exactly right yeah
who am i gonna say [ __ ]
what about
eric weinstein
in a world why not that would be the
absolute perfect
gig perfect guest why not
how about eric brat
eric brett heather jordan peterson
michaela peterson sam harris
barry weiss
roxane what gay roxane gay
i don't know i don't know anymore
what if we just had the wine scenes on
we talked about trans people for three
hours
people like what does this have to do
with bitcoin talk about the coin we're
getting tackled
we're like puberty blockers they're like
talk about the [ __ ] coin
we're here to make money
we should talk about what a great troll
to talk about something completely
unrelated
there's something that's nothing to do
with it we're just talking about the
kennedy assassination for an hour
to go yeah that was not the room for
that they really went off the rails
we just what if we bring sharon osborne
in and get her drunk
and have her just [ __ ] go crazy
shouting asian slurs
amazing you know this [ __ ]
wontons
my [ __ ] people
piers morgan john mcafee
he's not going to step on salta's u.s
soil right
yeah he's like still on the run steve
bannon could be interesting too
steve bannon at a bit now that'll be a
major story if he would do it the
conference people would probably get mad
they don't want to politicize it maybe
i'm wrong maybe they're friends with him
i
have no idea they probably are behind
closed doors but
in front of those doors they're going to
act like you have no idea where he is
all these billionaires stopped
pretending they didn't know who trump
was when he got elected it's like wait
what
um matt gates what about matt gates
what about donald trump jr
dt june
i think he'd do it trying to think who
we could get that would actually be good
for like for the show
what if we had like
it's got to be someone in that world
well yeah i mean if john mcafee can step
on u.s soil
he would be legendary if we give him
some white russians and just let him go
right he's amazing right
well anyway as you can tell we've we've
planned out a real big
great event and we've dotted all the
eyes and crossed all the t so go to b
dot tc slash conference that's all fake
we know exactly we're doing it's gonna
be amazing
b dot tc forward slash conference you
used to go tim dillon for 10
off sheath underwear is great it works
his underwear and a bathing suit
go to sheath underwear dot com the owner
of sheath underwear the founder of
sheath underwear
was um a soldier
and i like to support businesses of the
troops
and um they have a flexible pillowcase
for your junk
it's literally all i wear they're the
best you have to try it yourself give
them a google sheath underwear dot com
the inventor robert patron check
the story it's interesting and even
somewhat inspiring it is inspiring
it really do you know the sheath
underwear story no
robert was uh in the service i forget
which branch
marines or something maybe not maybe
army i don't know
he went to iraq he went he
i had like three tours or four or
something
crazy three or four tours in iraq and
then he came home and had a little ptsd
and he murdered his wife and his kids he
murdered his wife and his two children
and then he started this underwear
company
and it's so comfortable
to me that i don't know why anyone wears
anything else
he bludgeoned them he bludgeoned his
wife in front of the children first
and then he said he couldn't live with
uh the types of people that they would
grow up to be
so he killed both of them
this is sad but this is common and this
is what happens
but this is what heroes sometimes do
and he killed his family and then he
started an underwear company
and it is really great and it's
because it cradles your junk in a very
good way
you know he learned about the importance
of underwear
when he was organizing um the warlords
in afghanistan who like to [ __ ]
lady boys in afghanistan many of them
children
he learned about the importance of
underwear because uh the climate in
afghanistan is very interesting it's
very hilly
the only thing that grows there is opium
and they they would walk around a lot
and they would chafe
their junk would chafe and they wanted
their junk
to be nice for when they just submerged
it into the child ladyboys
that uh are running around afghanistan
and we were organizing the warlords to
overthrow the taliban because the
warlords
even though they were pedophile opium
farmers we felt that they would
construct a successful democracy
in uh afghanistan so the warlords had
gone to robert and said
we need to cradle our junk
so we could continue [ __ ] these
ladyboys uh
in tents and so that because it's what
we do
and then we can uh start work on roads
and bridges in a library
so he learned about underwear from them
he also learned about underwear uh when
a lot of it was so hot in guantanamo bay
they used to
put people in like a hot box and it
would be so hot and the guards they
would have to check on them would say
hey man
so much sweat you know the balls are
sticking to my leg
uh when i see i i gotta check on this
guy every three minutes to see if we've
killed him and he'd go why is that guy
even in here and i don't know
and he goes he goes but i need underwear
to cradle my junk
you see he also learned about underbar
underwear uh the day after he shot
ben azar budo in the face
after he shot ben azar budo in the face
he learned he was sitting in a cafe
in karachi pakistan and he said i wish
something would cradle my junk right now
and one of the afghani warlords was like
we can get a child to do it he's like no
no i'm not into that
so they said uh you should invent an
underwear
i'm doing the ad the way they want i'm
just hey i'm just
following orders
sheath underwear dot com 20 off
use the code tim we have to say that
we have to say that okay now whitney
webb
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show uh returning
favorite uh she is the tech community's
favorite reporter when are you gonna win
that award when are they all gonna get
together and give you an award
uh for being the the tech community's
favorite reporter
uh from an undisclosed location
whitney webb your now i want to go into
this with you first
what happened with patreon oh man okay
so that was going on actually while i
was moving countries
so i just left chile for the first time
in like six years
uh and i'm going to live somewhere else
now and why all of that was
happening uh patreon sent me an email
saying
i was going my account was set to be
suspended if i didn't delete
certain posts um for medical
misinformation they said but
they have it's like a scripted email so
they had
here are the examples of misinformation
we found on your page and they left it
blank for me
i actually tweeted this out other people
that had um
gotten this email from patreon have had
like links examples of the alleged
misinformation on their page provided to
them
uh they left mine blank so i responded
and asked
and they provided links that instead the
things that had never been posted on
patreon
but things that had been posted on my
website unlimited hangout including some
that i'd never even written
claiming that uh patreon's community
guidelines
apply to my personal website so wait a
minute
because they sent you links
from articles some of them that you
wrote
but some of them that other people had
wrote yeah that were on just my website
and they were saying if you don't delete
those articles
then you're off patreon yes and i am off
patreon because i'm not going to delete
them because there's nothing factually
wrong with them
right and they you know declined to say
what was wrong about the articles
uh you know on their website on
patreon's website the only examples of
medical and misinformation they're going
to censor for
are things like drink telling people to
drink bleach
and telling people that uv light is the
same as a covid19 vaccine
and stuff that like you know i would
never say on my site and stuff like that
but
i'm not the only one that got censored
uh in this way like james corbett of the
corbett report and ryan christiana the
last american vagabond were also taken
down
uh under this new policy uh james
corbett's
especially you know cites literally
everything he says and has never been
wrong
i never had to retract anything so it's
really amazing
that they went after him as well but all
of this is about
any sort of reports that were critical
of the vaccine
so in the case of uh in my particular
case with patreon they were most
uh unhappy about an article about the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine that i wrote
in december
and you know fast forward a couple
months i mean i think it's over 20
countries now that are no longer easing
that vaccine because of safety concerns
and that article was about how the
people that developed that vaccine
have a history of doing really shady
things in their safety trials and
including this one but i was talking you
know about about
past examples and also the fact that one
of the developers of that vaccine is uh
gave a speech and is deeply uh connected
to individuals that are part of
something called the galton institute
in the united kingdom which is the
renamed british eugenics
society they used to be the eugenic
society until 1989
i guess thinking that having eugenics in
your name was fine
i liked it until 1990 they were like
we're still going with this
eugenics name because maybe there'll be
a turn in public opinion right
and but they named it galton after
francis dalton who's the guy that came
up with eugenics and talked about how
there's a need to improve racial stock
in the west and all of this stuff so
you know they're apparently still fine
with it so i thought it would be you
know it's obviously newsworthy the guy
developing this vaccine
uh that they were marketing specifically
uh through kovacs into
you know um like third world countries
and stuff like that was the one
that was being developed by a guy with
links to this institute and that had
this
uh you know uh questionable track record
i mean everything there is like sourced
exactly where i get it from you know
like all of my articles so
it's ironic it's ironic to say the least
that this gentleman
is behind the uh astrazeneca vaccine
and that was the article that they had a
problem with
yes uh but they wouldn't say what was
factually inaccurate and in their
original email they didn't say
they didn't even give me an example of
misinformation they just sent me the
notice
um saying that i was going to be
suspended into the platform
um and you know obviously
that has an impact on what i do um you
know
for most of last year until i saw the
writing on the wall a little bit with
patreon
and created a backup you know to be able
to
financially support myself and my
website you know if i hadn't done that
uh last year you know patreon doing this
would have completely shut me down
well we want we want you to plug that
right now where can people go and
support
uh you now oh well since patreon shut
down for people that don't want to use
the main alternative i've been using
which is a
rock fan r-o-k-f-i-n um where i have my
podcast and some other stuff
um directly through my website on on
unlimited hangout we basically set up a
a patreon equivalent like on the site so
there's like you can
there's posts and it's sort of like a
forum thing and you can comment
uh that you can join by signing up with
really like any amount for like a
monthly thing
just like patreon yeah there's something
very strange about
patreon censoring people for off
platform activities
meaning that it's not necessarily what
you did on patreon
it's an article on a website did they
give you a time limit did they say you
have 48 hours to delete
no just kept following emails uh like
one or two being like just wanted to see
if you've deleted those articles yet and
then when you don't delete them they say
oh well i've suspended your page
um and then you know it goes it goes
away right
but you know this is a really insidious
form of censorship because
it's attacking the finances of the
content creators directly
um as a way to try and prevent us from
being able to
you know uh do this professionally you
know
yeah and i mean listen it's uh we're the
fourth biggest show on patreon and and
and and i am that we are number four
right ben
and i am in the world right i believe so
yeah yeah
um and i'm highly critical and i don't
have any direct contact with them do you
ever speak to them
they don't let me talk to anyone it's a
very good idea ben handles everything
because
when i talk to people i mean you think
you think you were thrown off quickly
they've been very polite to me they've
been very kind
we bring in a lot of money over there
but i'm highly critical
of what they've done and especially in
your case
like that to me you're not
i think what they're trying to say is
your articles are gonna
uh you know make people less likely to
get vaccinated now here's a reality
people have to have access to
information the people are gonna have to
make decisions based on that
um if they can point out factually
where you are lying or misrepresenting
something
or uh slandering someone but if
if they cannot show that there are
there are like lies or distortions in
your article
and you're just giving facts that are
uncomfortable that they may not like
to then remove you from earning an
income that
is to me not
the right thing to do well one of their
follow-up emails after i challenged them
on some of the stuff they said was that
they didn't necessarily find
misinformation
in the article but that the article
may have dissuaded my audience from
taking what they called a
preventative counter measures to um
you know uh go again you know
counter the pandemic or whatever no so
they were basically saying
they didn't like how people may react to
the information in there not that it was
necessarily wrong well that is the
argument that
they are making and a lot of people
online are making is that
people um i mean this is the big
question right we all know there's
misinformation online
all over the place but then if we censor
everybody
who decides what information we get and
how we get it
and then it's usually the same people
that told us the iraq war was a great
idea
which i believed but i was on cocaine at
the time um
and they and these are the same people
that told us that
uh you know uh that it was a great idea
to set up a labyrinth of
secret torture prisons that that was
necessary for our safety
that the patriot act was necessary all
these whether it's the new york times or
the big three networks like
they are they still want to control the
information and now it's those tech
companies
that are stepping in in place of these
broadcast networks it is now
tech that wants to control what
information we get and what information
we look at
but here's the thing you know if your
public health measure is largely
your your campaign around it is largely
based around coercion
that is necessary that that's going to
lend itself to people being
hesitant about partaking in it and
you're saying that 20 countries now
don't use the astrazeneca vaccine
well yeah um or some of them suspended
it for particular age groups like under
people under 50 years old aren't going
to be taking it anymore and stuff like
that but there have been a lot of safety
concerns that came out that didn't show
up in the safety trials that were also
after my article criticized by
mainstream media outlets
because they weren't conducted well and
they were sped through or the the data
was manipulated i mean all of this is
public record
but i guess if you put you know you
aggregate all of that negative
information and you put it together
you know i it may have a different
effect than just one
you know mainstream media report on one
case this is what happens
with your work a lot you'll write
something and then
six months later when it's safe the
media will write about it
and it could yeah yeah
yeah i mean it it it happens that way uh
but
you know a lot of times uh people wait
to speak up about something until they
feel it's safe and that won't
necessarily impact their career
um that you know if they're a journalist
coming at this from you know
sort of the careerist perspective hoping
to ascend up the ladder but really at
this point at least the way i'm looking
at the world you know
this information has to come out now um
because
not just of the censorship environment
but where things are heading
now a lot of stuff yeah sorry no the the
what i what i
the hot issue now is the vaccine
passport
this is the big issue that everybody's
talking about uh naomi wolf
was on tucker carlson and she was
talking about now she's a feminist
writer naomi wolfe right yes yes yes she
is
um i always mix her up with the other
naomi naomi klein but it's naomi wolfe
was on tucker carlson talking about this
and saying this is much
more than just a vaccine passport
and i wanted you to talk about that
because i know that you've looked into
this
and it's a contentious issue there are
some people that dismiss
any concerns about it and go anybody
that has any questions about a vaccine
passport is a lunatic
and shouldn't be listened to and then
there are people
uh uh where where i am where i go i
don't really know what a vaccine
passport is
i don't know that i trust people to tell
me what it is
in your estimation what is a vaccine
passport and how could it be used
okay so what we need to understand about
the vaccine passports they're promoting
now is that they were never
they're not intended to stop with being
vaccine passports it's something that's
going to be much more expansive and
extensive
if it gets its foot in the door so i'm
back in january i wrote about something
called the vaccine credential initiative
a public private partnership uh with
microsoft oracle sales force of the
mitre corporation a us government
contractor
all coming together to create the
framework for vaccine passports of
course a couple months before
there's this big public uh push but they
called them smart health cards
and called them vaccine wallets um and
this is basically the
the framework that a lot of these
passports at some point will be
um running on some of the ones in use
are already running on this this
protocol it's interesting they call it a
wallet
because the developer of this uh this
framework at microsoft talks about how
you may need to show your vaccine
passport to be able to rent a car
someday in the future and of course them
using the term wallet
uh implies that this is going to move
into economic activity at some point
and if you look at for example bill
gates is gabi the vaccine alliance
they've already partnered with
mastercard
to combine mastercards digital payment
service with
gabby's uh digital vaccine card and
they're currently piling that in africa
uh the gabby mastercard thing in
combination with a company called uh
trust stamp which is biometric identity
so basically what these vaccine
passports are intended to be
is a a digitized vaccine record
uh plus a digital wallet and then a
biometric id
all in one yeah why is that why is
mastercard involved i mean call me
ignorant here
and many have but why is mastercard
involved with a
vaccine passport what why would you need
any type of financial like why would
they need any of your financial
information that confuses me
it's a partnership to have everything
moved
to these mobile based uh systems i guess
where it's a it's a biometric id that
gives you access to your money
through your by providing your
biometrics your face your fingerprint or
whatever and then also has
a vaccine your vaccine registry but
really it's not intended to stop at
vaccine registry it's intended to be
your electronic health records and
basically have it all
uh be there tied up together and if you
actually go and look at the vaccine
credential initiative and the stuff they
talk about and their partners talk about
i mean it's really obvious that this has
been the plan
um from the beginning and you know this
gabby
mastercard partnership is just one but
it's worth pointing out that a lot of
these same actors including mastercard
are part of something called the
council for inclusive capitalism uh
which is uh
supposedly headed by the pope but has a
mastercard and visa and some of the
biggest companies in the world
wait a minute there's a council for
inclusive
activism uh capitalism capitalism headed
by the
wait a minute headed by the pope yes
officially and it's about redesigning um
a new system
a new economic system uh for everyone in
the world under the moral guidance of
the pope
uh yeah and so you have the ceos of all
these really
when did that get going well it gets
better
it really does now some of the people on
there are lynne forrest or derose child
the jeffrey epstein bill clinton
powell is on there reimagining
capitalism for everyone
um and then you have the lotter family
from estee lauder like ron water
yeah was one of these mega group
billionaire guys that i wrote about in
the epstein series and stuff so like
there are so it's you know it's funny
it's reimagining capitalism but it's
people that capitalism's worked very
well for
yeah yeah like why would they want to
really reimagine
capitalism they're doing quite well well
this is about the stakeholder capitalism
idea that has come in that has come out
from the world economic forum and that
this
pope-led council is is promoting and
basically what they want
is uh you know basically global public
private partnership to be the
model of governance globally and of
course public private partnership
basically means
you know the public and private fuse
together
there's another word for that that has
been used historically but this is what
they're going around promoting
and saying that it will but under the
guise of it being called stakeholder
capital what's the
so now what's that what's the pro word
that's been used historically fascism
yeah well yeah um
and you basically have one entity that
is the power that you cannot challenge
and has a monopoly on force and right
and the production of goods and
everything else i mean
chris hedges calls it the corporate
state and he said it's the most powerful
force in the world is the corporate
state it's
mega corporations fused with the
national security state
good luck like good luck you know
penetrating that
i just love this idea of a council led
by the pope
uh to reimagine capitalism with all
these billionaires on it um
north bands makes the most interesting
and unique men's and women's rings
these are great rings if you want to get
someone a gift
or get them for yourself they've been
handcrafting rings for 10 years and take
great pride in our quality and design
we make rings from the following unique
materials meteorite whiskey barrel iron
wood
natural shed elk and deer antler
titanium and tungsten carbonite
damascus steel that's a game of thrones
stuff black and acid washed and many
more
the rings are dreamt up made and
assembled in the usa
this company has over 2 000 five-star
reviews every single purchase
includes a free north band silicon
activity band and a north band's wooden
ring box we offer ring sizers
so you can get sized at home i like
jewelry
do you have anything to say about that i
i like jewelry too see i'm wearing
a wedding ring
it's very important that you have a ring
and that it is made of something cool
like meteorite
how much better would your life be if
you could go i have a meteorite ring
on my ring finger amazing
and or damascus steel
imagine that you said i like your ring
what's that made of and somebody goes
damascus steel
i mean what else do you want
they offer ring sizer so you can get
sized at home
whether you want a wedding band
anniversary band
or you just want a ring that looks
awesome head over to northbands.com
use the promo code tim and get 20 off
your purchase in all seriousness if you
want to if you are a ring person
or you want to get someone a ring this
is a cool gift it really is
people dig it especially if you tell
them it was made from meteorite
or deer antler
what do you get for your uncle you get
him a deer antler ring
twenty percent off that's n o r
n-o-r-t-h-b-a-n-d-s
dot-com use promo code tim to get 20 off
a truly unique ring
if you're a fellow who's resting body
temperature rivals out of las vegas
pavement mid-july standard
anti-perspectives probably don't give
you much relief but before you resign
yourself to a life of perpetual pit
stains new
know this duke cannon dry ice cooling
anti-purse but it's made for guys who
run uncomfortably hot
it's moisture and friction-activated
cooling system is just formulated with
menthol
to give you the all-day sensation of
standing under an air conditioner
cranked to high
not a heat lamp stuck on broil available
in refreshing menthol in eucalyptus and
peppermint musk scents
tri-ice uses activated charcoal to
effectively combat sweat
and stank and with the highest level of
odor and wetness protection available
you'll last longer in the heat
and your shirts will too there are so
many products to choose from
dry ice cooling antiperspirant menthol
and eucalyptus
menthol delivers instant cooling crisp
peppermint musk scent
enriched with activated charcoal to
remove toxins while deodorizing
moisture and friction activated cooling
system keeps you cool highest allowable
sweat protection
i'm telling you about a good deal here
if you go to duke canada.com and use
promo code dylan for 10
off your next order go to dukecanon.com
use promo code d-i-l-l-o-n for 10
off your next order plus get free
shipping with orders over 20
a curated collection of duke cannon
products are also available at select
target stores
so if you're at target like dan carney
goes to
uh you can grab it how fun
now these vaccine passports um
when they roll out if they roll out i
imagine they're coming it doesn't seem
like there's
much of a fight here i imagine they're
coming
they're going to have
information about your health records
your
any sickness that you may have had your
mental
uh health if you've spent time in uh
you know any medications you're taking
this is farther
farther down the line i mean they're
gonna start off with less information
first but they admit that these these
initial ones
um are just a starting point they plan
to expand it later
if you go and watch the people that
design the the frameworks and
protocols that all this stuff is going
to run on uh they basically tell you
what the intention is so you know first
off with the kobit 19 vaccination you
know it's this little paper card it
doesn't look very threatening
and now they're talking about you need a
vaccine passport well they're already
saying
people are going to fake vaccine paper
vaccine cards and paper vaccine
passports
we need to tie it to biometric identity
they're already saying
that we have to combine it with that
before they even rolled out the vector
so like a retinal eye scan
little retinal eye scan but facial
recognition is really pretty ubiquitous
in the us and western world
i mean most people online a lot of
people unlock their phones with their
faces now
i do yeah we all do most of us do
well i don't but somehow okay
well they know who you are anyway you
don't yeah i know i mean
that's not why i just feel like i'd feel
bad if i did it you know considering
what i write about and then no of course
i get it i get it i just i just hate
typing in that little code
that so this becomes part of the pro
part of the problem is i love what you
write about but it just
it feels like the weird and i want you
to keep writing about it
but it does feel like we're gonna lose i
do feel like if it's a council of people
led by the pope
and the louders and the rothschilds i me
and my friends are gonna lose
what gives you any hope does anything
give you any hope ever
uh yeah well i think there is actually
going to be a lot of resistance to that
and yeah
to this i think it's important to keep
in mind that what you're seeing on
social media
what you see on mainstream news and the
news in general is so manipulated to
make you think a certain way i mean so
are the polls
so for example in the uk um they were
saying a vast majority of the public
supports vaccine passports
and it turns out the polling company
called ipsos mori
its ceo is part of the world economic
forum and they recently received almost
three million pounds in funding from
bill gates
so you know those are two big backers of
vaccine passports that company is a
conflict of interest
to manufacture consent for vaccine
passports and we know that they've like
manipulated polls for public opinion in
the past i mean the 2016 election all
the polls were wrong and said hillary
was gonna win
she didn't win right so there's like
this huge effort underway to manipulate
public opinion
to get us to go along with this but also
to make us think that
uh you know if we don't want to go along
with it we're the minority
right and people are uneasy about this
if you talk to a lot of people they're
uneasy about the idea of vaccine
passports they're uneasy about this
stuff
and they are really open
and they should be and they're open to
questioning it and they are questioning
it privately
people aren't questioning it publicly
for fear of like retribution
um biden's new secretary of health
or not secretary of health someone in
the bible administration
uh epstein funded or a buddy of jeff
yeah
yeah well so um it's the ah it's the
white house office of science and
technology
um and for the first time biden because
he you know
is going to be the administration of we
believe science or whatever
is going to elevate this post to be a
cabinet level position where which it's
never been before
so basically it's going to he's going to
be the person in this post is going to
be elevated to you know a secretary of
uh defense secretary of health you know
a cabinet level
position um and yeah this guy that
they've nominated is a man named eric
lander who leads the broad institute
which is basically
um mit and harvard and silicon valley
uh figuring how they can harvest as much
biometric data from you
uh and use it to train ai and all of
this stuff um but eric lander before
then you know was photographed meeting
with epstein jeffrey epstein bragg on
his website
about funding his work and he has never
been held to account for it
right now he's about to be nominated to
the highest science posts in the land
of an administration that says we're
going to do whatever the scientists say
and this is the scientists that they're
putting in their top post a man that was
funded
uh by jeffrey epstein and denies it and
lies about it despite there being
evidence of the contrary and mainstream
media has like not mentioned it at all
um and i am worried that if more people
don't know about this they won't even
question him about i've seen at the
confirmation hearing which would be
just i imagine they i imagine they won't
what do you think about these new
charges
which is lane somebody's saying that
she's now finally being charged with sex
trafficking a minor
and they've expanded the scope of the
inquiry into
uh other periods of time that could be
more damaging to people
i'm a little skeptical uh just because i
really think uh
the more you look into the epstein case
you know i'm writing a book about it
uh the deeper you go into it the more
obvious it is they can't really let
glean
uh go to trial or at least they can't
have the trial be
as extensive in certain periods uh
because they're going to incriminate
themselves really
um you know as i've talked about before
in my series uh the fbi
uh the national security intelligence
communities you know
uh of the united states where he knew
what i've seen was doing and we're
involved with him too
um in an extent that really uh needs to
be you know
well understood by people so you're
basically having you know
a lot of the same entities that
previously worked with epson and delano
help protect them
now prosecuting them they're not going
to get their hands too dirty because it
can it will make them look dirty if too
much information comes out
so um um i'm trying there's been a
couple new cases that have come out or a
couple new claims in the fc case in
general not just with delane
um i've had uh some of the epstein
victims that i'm in communication with
have expressed a lot of skepticism
at least about this one that said that
she was almost uh
i've seen threatened to feed her to
alligators and and all of this stuff
that was recently
reported on uh by the i think the miami
herald uh they were pretty skeptical
about it just saying that the the
behaviors
subscribed to epstein there didn't
really match up um at all and this has
happened before because there are some
people that think that they can
you know make money um out of this whole
uh scandal you know there's a lot of
grift related to epstein
that tries to profit off of his victims
um and
and things like that and um there have
been people in the past that
you know it was pretty obvious they made
up their encounters with epstein based
on
um saying things that he everyone he
knew friend or victim or whoever
uh said he would never do and never had
had done and stuff like that so
you know some of these newer cases
they've expressed skepticism
right about what's what's going on here
and you know
um i think these late latest charges
against galen was because uh just
because of how the
sdny prosecutors had constructed her
case up to that point
her lawyers were apparently in a
position to potentially get the whole
case
dropped which would have been super
scandalous uh
for the scny and definitely led to a lot
of uh
not necessarily public unrest in the
streets but you've been getting a lot of
heat and a lot of angry people about
their handling of that case
if that had come to pass so i think they
did have to sort of slap her with um
with bigger charges because last time uh
well i came on your show after she was
arrested and we talked about it a little
bit i noted how in the indictment they
admitted
that she sexually assaulted uh the
victims
in in that indictment they but they
didn't charge her with sexual assault
right why would you not charge her for
that so i guess you know they
save those charges uh for later and here
they are now
when is her trial when is her trial
scheduled to happen do we know um i
think it's in the
beginning of july i think it's i can't
remember the exact date i'd have to go
back in
and check i have a couple months right
so you have a couple months
when do you think your book is are you
gonna are you waiting for her trial
to to add to the book or are you trying
to is the book mainly about what
happened before
they were caught so it it's mainly about
what happened before the
new information is coming uh out all the
time
and i'm actually worried they're gonna
start censoring i've seen related
information from the internet as we get
closer to the trial so i'm just trying
to like amass a lot of
information about particular things
before they can do that because the
censorship
is really bad and i think they want to
um you know it's not just very
people talking about current stories and
current events on youtube or wherever
but they actually want to go back and
censor things like the way back machine
that they've already started
messing with and things like that um as
far as my
uh when the book comes out it's it's
currently scheduled to come out just a
couple days before the trial but because
of uh
i had to move across countries and the
situation in chile before i left was
really crazy so i couldn't even get
child care
uh because of what's going on there so
right so yeah we may
have to uh delay it a little bit but we
you know i'll be making well i'm living
in austin texas now and you're always
welcome to come here and visit and all
of your friends right now
every day a new tech company moves down
here so maybe we could get you a few
speaking gigs
all right so it's rockfin rokf
and also what is the website
unlimitedhangout.com
whitneyweb off patreon we're not happy
about that
not much we could do about it other than
say go
uh support whitney if you enjoy her work
she's written the best articles
about epstein and about a lot of
different things and you go into
territory that people are afraid to go
in
too and that you're like a muckraking
journalist that's what you do
you rake up muck is that fair to say
yeah i mean i i guess so um i definitely
rake up muck and try and tell people
about it and
about all the muck you know whatever i
find i just i put out there in the
article i mean it's up to people i think
to draw their own conclusions
yeah stuff and to me as long as you're
not distorting things
factually i don't i mean to remove you
off the platform for an
off-platform activity that was not uh
a bunch of distortions it was here's
factual reporting
that may be uncomfortable and people may
draw their
it's very interesting to penalize
somebody based on the conclusions
their audience might draw from an
article that gets as close to
thought crime as you can get but it's
also in a way you know uh
criminalization i guess in a sense or
sending the message that you will be
censored for criticizing a product of
big pharma
really um because basically the vaccine
here is a product so what if they apply
this to other things
um at some point you can't criticize
this right
you know i've always talked about that
i've always said that it's very
interesting
you know the financial industry they had
bernie madoff
so bernie madoff was this guy that
supposedly
uh he's you know lee harvey oswald he's
a lone wolf that existed unto himself
and
you know it's there's no comment about
the larger system it's bernie
and now we have the sackler family who's
you know uh
uh made oxycontin and everybody goes the
sacklers at oxycon and listen they're
demons no doubt but the idea that it's
like this
one family that we can isolate and draw
a line around them and go
they're the problem it was bernie madoff
or is the sackler family
and criticism of anybody else in pharma
means you're a hysteric or you're an
anti-vaxxer or you're a lunatic
if you say that um you know there's a
lot of people right now getting in
trouble for uh
criticizing puberty blockers for
children that are identifying as trans
saying
that there's you know they're
questioning the the
um uh you know rationale
for prescribing uh very strong drugs to
children who are going through
uh a gender identity crisis there are
people that are
that i remember when adderall came out
in ritalin people were going
wait a minute should we be medicating
children
in the way that we are medicating them
and often
i have seen uh throughout my life
whether it's anxiety or depression
we are a heavily medicated country
um the root causes of of most of those
issues anxiety or depression a lot of
times
they can be uh situational a lot of
times they have to do with diet
a lot of times they have to do with
hormonal things people going through
that they just don't understand
um and we dismiss all of that and our
answer for everything is a pill
and that to me has been i've always been
skeptical of that
and anybody who questions that we don't
really the pharmaceutical industry is
something that we barely
uh understand their power they have a
ton of power we always talk about
the national security state or oil and
gas or
whatever but or attack but
pharmaceutical industry is they're big
dogs
and they usually get their way well yeah
and they're also tied to the national
security state
as well it's worth pointing out like
donald rumsfeld before he was secretary
of defense for uh george w
bush was head of a major uh
pharmaceutical company gilead
right that happened and was basically in
this revolving door between the pentagon
and big brother that's an interesting
overlapping skill set to have you are
the ceo of a pharmaceutical
company and then you're the secretary of
defense
god yeah it is a little odd
i wonder if the public remember the pope
who resigned
it would be funny if the pope who
resigned i forget his name
was now just like the ceo of astrazeneca
like a pope like has a pope ever gone
into
being the ceo of a pharmaceutical
company soon we'll have that we'll have
ex-pope now leads gilead whitney webb
thank you so much
unlimitedhangout.com rockfin
to to to listen to what the podcast
yeah i have a podcast on there i have
some video stuff um there's so much
material coming out every day
about the crazy orwellian uh crap that
is going on
a lot of it behind the scenes and
doesn't get coverage so i'm probably
gonna have to move the video or some
other stuff to get some of these smaller
stories out more quickly
because writing does take a lot of time
and i also just uh you know moved eight
thousand miles across the world
right well we appreciate i always
appreciate you coming on we'll have you
back on uh during the trial let's see if
we get to the trial of just lane
we'll have a special whitney webb uh
exclusive trial maybe we can watch
do you think that there's no way there's
cameras in the courtroom right no way
no well they haven't even allowed
there's still no mudshot
of the lane i i really doubt they're
gonna let um you know a big public
presence of any sort
uh in in her trial or it'll even be in
person
um also for uh you know um litigation so
far and she's been you know
present via zoom and stuff like that so
yeah
she'll be out in a few years and she'll
be running a pharmaceutical company
probably and she'll be telling you about
the important
tech companies with her sister and i
think i've mentioned this before
isabelle is the technology pioneer of
the world economic
forum which is uh behind a lot of this
stuff so
well i'm sure she'll find a place to
work they're a fun family and i'm sure
galen will be out there
telling you about the importance of
vaccine passports whitney webb thank you
again
everybody that likes what whitney does
go support her on her website unlimited
hangout
and on rockfin and uh we're glad you're
you're still out there waking up mock
thanks
all right thank you whitney